un salut militaire dans la peau d'un
nouveau rôle celui de commandant en chef
des armées
joe biden s'est rendu dans un édifice
empreint d'histoire
le président américain attentif aux lors
de sa visite guidée d'une exposition
rendre hommage au personnel
afro-américain des armées enjoy dance
scruter et déterminés à répondre aux
défis des adversaires des états unis
aujourd'hui j'ai été informé d'un
nouveau groupe de travail du département
de la défense sur la chine que deux
secrétaires austin a mis en place pour
examiner notre stratégie est le concept
opérationnel notre technologie notre
dispositif de forces et bien d'autres
choses encore
le 46e président américain rappelle un
effort de l'ensemble du gouvernement
face aux questions liées à l' empire du
milieu avec deux maîtres mots alliances
et partenariats solides un futur groupe
de travail composé de quinze conseillers
civils et militaires c'est ainsi que
nous relèverons le défi de la chine et
veilleront à ce que le peuple américain
gagne la compétition de l'avenir la
maison blanche a informé dans la foulée
de cette visite au pentagone d'un coup
de fil entre le président chinois xi
jinping et son homologue américain le
premier depuis l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche
pratique économique contraignantes hong
kong taïwan ou encore le dossier des
ouigours beaucoup de divergences dans
une compétition stratégique
de son côté pékin via son média d'état
joue l'apaisement
les questions relatives à ce sujet
concerne la souveraineté et l'intégrité
territoriale de la chine la partie
américaine devrait traiter ces questions
avec prudence le gouvernement chinois
espère une meilleure relation bilatérale
citant un moment crucial dans leurs
relations
les ministères des affaires étrangères
des deux pays peuvent avoir un échange
de vues approfondis sur les relations
bilatérales et les grandes questions
internationales et régionales
les ministères de l'économie des
finances de la police et de l'armée
peuvent avoir davantage de contacts la
chine et les états unis devraient
rétablir différents types de mécanismes
de dialogue pour mieux comprendre les
intentions politiques de l'autre éviter
les malentendus et les erreurs de
jugement la pandémie de kobe de 19 et le
changement climatique au centre
également des discussions entre les deux
dirigeants
l' usage de la force doit être le
dernier recours a fait remarquer joe
biden au sujet de sa future politique
étrangère